bonjour et bienvenue sur des gones à la
leçon dernière émission concernant la
sicilienne d'âge d'or donc je trouve
cette émission j'ai le plaisir de
recevoir stéphane leroux laborde
bonjour stéphane un jour et loi je
regardais encore une fois le générique
ce super mme matte du berger qu'on
recommande aux débutants quand même oui
tout à fait tout à fait maths du berger
qui donc est une arme très efficace
puisque ça permet de la télé en quatre
ans seulement donc c'est quand même
extrêmement rapide enfin là nous allons
parler aujourd'hui de la défense nash
dorff système avec 6 g iii donc un
système avec g3 stéphane ça implique que
l'adversaire donc le joueur qui a les
blancs puisque nous nous jouons la
défense majorque avec les noirs jouent
solide a priori pas forcément pour
gagner
ouais je sais quelque chose très solide
il va essayer de me poser un étonnant à
roxy avec ses 4 notamment ça arrive ça
arrive et c'est bien c'est quelque chose
de pas très très dangereux puisque le
fou est caché derrière son pion le pian
2 4 donc c'est une variante qui est
plutôt défensive du coup tu es blanc
exactement donc tout de suite pour
commencer cette analyse de 6 jan des
joueurs que nous allons mettre la
position la position donc pour l'instant
la position de départ on va vous
détailler les premiers coups et donc on
verra comment les blancs peuvent tenter
des choses après j'ai 3 comment bien
réagir du côté noir puisque c'est notre
souci principal bien comprendre la
sicile and night of avec les noirs donc
tout de suite eu quatre vous vous avez
les noirs vous jouer c'est simple la
cécilienne tout ça stéphane on l'a déjà
commenté de nombreuses fois qu'elles
vivent trois lycées 6 des quatre pions
prend des quatre kelly prend des 4 c'est
un ordre de coups un peu différent dame
ces sept on voit que ça retransmise dans
la position qui essaient 3e 6 j'ai trois
à six fours j'ai deux cavaliers f6 petit
rock des six
voilà donc la position on y arrive par
un autre homme de coups qu'on verra tout
à l'heure on reconnaît notre nash dorff
avec cette fameuse formation option on a
sorti de caliance et 6ème cavagnan m6 on
a mis la d'avancé 7 également on
reviendra sur lot de coups dans la
partie suivante puisque là c'est un
autre ordre de coûts qui a été choisie
par les deux joueurs et on voit que les
blancs ont mis leurs fous en g2 alors
comme tu dit stéphane premier remarque
c'est que le fou est bloqué
par son propre père on voit la seule
chose il faut faire attention du côté
noir c'est la poussée e45 qui peut être
dangereuse étant donné que le tour à 8
pour l'instant est sous le feu du fou g2
donc on le verra régulièrement dans
pratiquement toutes les variantes les
noirs ont des problèmes pour jouer les
plans avec des seins qui voit là parce
que justement les cinq serait une faute
les cinq sur une faute puisqu'il ya eu
cinq attaques le câble six attaques
également encaissé 6 et en plus ils à
tours habite derrière donc c'est
hautement problématique de jouer avec
des cinq dans cette position c'est aux
blancs de jouer donc ça c'est la
position de base vraiment la pression de
base que vous obtiendrez à chaque fois
que votre adversaire joue rage et trois
premières tentatives des blancs c'est un
coup d'abord curieux c'est le coup
cavaliers ce2 alors stéphane on se dit
pourquoi on voit la belle idée c'est que
le purin 4 et protégé maintenant par le
fou donc ce cavalier peuvent être être
bouger ce qui est fait est l'idée des
blancs c'est de proposer au noir le
fameux et au delà roxy avec le coup ces
deux c4 qui empêche peut-être pas
définitivement mais pour un bon moment
là les pouces et libératrice des six des
cinq exactement donc des 6 décembre tout
de suite
c'est légèrement optimiste puisqu'il
peut y avoir des fouets quatre attaques
la dame et des cahiers français 6
éventuellement le pion au cap qui
avançons au 5
on n'a pas envie de le jouer tout de
suite des cinq et on ne pourra pas jouer
après donc il faut se préparer
psychologiquement à être enfermés
enfermé par le pion ces deux on sait car
une erreur tout de suite on va voir le
mirror possible ce serait dur usb 5
voilà pour l'instant chez c4 tout à fait
et là on voit que le fou j'ai 2 se
révèle puisque le cavalier c6 est
potentiellement en l'air ainsi que la
tour élite donc ici un jour et
vraisemblablement cavaliers procès si ce
cas les processus peut-être dame
processes il a sûrement le 5e 5
obligeant cavaliers des cinq forcé qui
est des cinq forcé mais ça c'est pas du
tout un plaisir pour les noirs en jouer
cavalier quatre peut-être sûrement cette
position il ya beaucoup d'options il ya
cavaliers des quatre qui est intéressant
qu'est c3 qui est très intéressant
cavalieri 4 aussi de toute façon on va
prendre en d5 et la structure des pions
noirs est très affaibli le roi stéphane
est toujours au centre alors on sait que
la position du roi c'est comme un
facteur très important dans l'évaluation
de la pollution est donc ici ce n'est
tout simplement pas possible
après qu'est et ce2 on ne peut pas jouer
mais cette baie 5 à cause du sujet donc
ça c'est une des premières idées des
blancs et juca et ce2
ils veulent tous les quatre
l'inconvénient pour les blancs stéphane
c'est bien entendu que ça perd beaucoup
de temps je perds du temps le camélia
bouger deux fois et puis le faut savoir
que les taux de maroc si c'est bon c'est
efficace pour empêcher des 5 mai les
pions blancs vont se retrouver eux-mêmes
figé en fait exactement donc content
pour lutter contre les taux de maroc si
on vous propose une partie modèle c'est
la partie donc madoff entre matthew
fitch qui a été joué évidemment en
yougoslavie avec des noms pareils c'est
évident fawcett c4 petit rock donc pour
l'instant rien de bien particulier
question pour les blancs qu'est ce
qu'ils font dans cette position bon ils
peuvent pas vraiment je le fous aux
trois puisque ça permettrait aux noirs
de jouer qu'ils aillent j'ai quatre
équipes au lieu de cinq avec des gains
de temps attaque l'option ces quatre
attaques le foudroie donc le
développement de ce fou c'est un est
déjà pas si évident ils choisissent donc
de tout et b3 voilà pour mettre le fond
de b2 qui est la case naturel dans
l'étau de la roxy pour les blancs qui
est une cause possible
le pion b3 défend plus le cuir ses
canons tout ça c'est très avantageux et
maintenant se pose vraiment la question
pour les noirs comment sortir ces pièces
stéphane voilà bombay tant d'années
qu'on peut pas jouer des scènes qui est
la case naturel du fou a l'air d'être la
case 17 exactement le fou s'est vite bon
alors normalement on veut jouer mais si
c'est faux bessette
ça c'est un plan tout à fait classique
placé mais là on ne peut pas toujours le
même problème s'ils ont des combos
champion b quel point ces 6 et de 5
et là tout de suite c'est terminé mais
là c'est pire que tout à l'heure puisque
même la cause des saints qui est protégé
par le pion donc sa perle à tours sa
perte tout de suite du matériel on joue
donc fou 17
normal me mettre c'est un coup qu'on
joue comme ça
four b2 et tour assez vite voilà ça y
est on a enlevé la tour du flux et
maintenant des 5 peut être à l'ordre du
jour
mais pas tout de suite puisque
maintenant le câble et des quatre
contrôle aussi la case des cinq mais
souvent peu joué et b5 avec l'idée que
quand les blancs prennent la case c3 où
ces deux est affaibli c'était fin donc
d'autant plus jouer cavalier prendrait
quatre tout de suite et ensuite b5
voilà ça c'est possible puisque le fou
17 contrôle des 5 donc en fait pour
résumer dans l'étau de la roxy qu'est ce
que vous avez envie de faire
eh bien vous avez envie de casser ceux
qui ont ces quatre de l'attaqué soit en
jouant des cinq fois champion des mais
ici c'est toujours très délicat soit en
avançant que l'on béquilles en général
beaucoup plus simple donc c'est pour ça
qu'on met deux fois en 17 ans mines
d'abord c4 avec b 5 pour ensuite pour
jouer des cinq plus facilement
exactement
donc ici on met le faux en 17 ans menace
de jouer pied prend des 4 et b5
donc ça c'est tout à fait normal on a
mis nos pièces au bon endroit
éventuellement la dame on pourrait la
remettre en b vite pour continuer à
aider à jouer des 5 et en plus libéré la
tour donc beaucoup davantage dans cette
position les bleus ont joué qui essaient
3 pour empêcher beisheim pour empêcher
des cinq a laissé trois contrôles mais
ça n'empêche pas vraiment on aurait pu
jouer qu'il prend des 4 es b sainte mais
on peut jouer aussi tous rêvent des huit
coups tout à fait classique et en
médiation centre et après qu'avait
laissé deux dames des vies tout
simplement avec une très belle position
menace b5 les blancs jouent dames deux
normales toujours pour empêcher les 5 et
là c'est là qu'il ya le coup clé dans
cette position c'est le coût 15
cavaliers à 7
maintenant bessin qui est imparable la
loi que j'ai passé toutes les pièces
noires donc se sont mises à la
protection de ce coup b5
les tours sont très bien placés pour une
ouverture de ligne le kawkab si c'est
pas si mal placé toutes les pièces
noires sont au top
on va jouer des 5 et ensuite la position
deviendra excellente pour les noirs
pourquoi parce que tout simplement les
bleus ont perdu trop de temps dans
l'ouverture mais après des scènes
comment pour aminé avec des quatre le
canal et ses trois fils devra bouger et
enlever une protection
ou à la casse des cinq exactement
exactement donc ça c'est ça fait partie
des idées ici vous avez un dynamisme
très fort
cette position est bonne en fait le plan
avec cavaliers ces deux gros neuvième
round n'est pas très dangereux on va
tout de suite passé stéphane à une autre
possibilité pour les blancs puisque
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de plans de jeu
différents c'est parti avec la partie
l'ati contre ifs kof
alors il coiffe on a peut-être le
remettre dans le contexte ça a été
pendant très longtemps le meilleur
joueur yougoslave
il est assez âgée aujourd'hui donc cette
partie date de 1969 quand il était au
top de sa forme et il comprenait
extrêmement bien là cécile end à geof
c'est donc un joueur 2.465 des quatre
qui comprend des quatre cavaliers f3
petite astuce ouais ça change pas grand
chose d interposition on peut pas on
peut peut-être joué au 5 et 5,5 à l'erp
au si oui ça faisait office de pions en
fait voilà c'est un simple puisque sur
cavaliers prend il y aurait damas cinq
échecs qui récupère les cavaliers qui
gagne le cavalier qui gagnent les
cavaliers donc eu 5 à l'art de gagner un
pion le 5 gagnants mais je crois qu'on
joue avec ses 3 après tout simplement on
joue ça dans un esprit de bambi et ça se
passe très bien aussi ce qu'est prend
des cadres donc là lors de coups et
toujours pas à l'ordre du jour à 6 g 3g
3 le fameux cavalli et 6 rouges et 2
donc si on joue dans l'ordre normal dans
sa position normale tuant des six
quelqu'un dise il choisit de wickens et
6 d'abord pour diverses raisons mais ça
c'est pas vraiment notre problème petit
roc dames c'est cette caisse et trois
des six et nous sommes dans la position
ouais bah voilà la position où on a vu
tout à l'heure qui avait dit co2 qui a
été tenté
ouais avec l'idée donc de jouer ces cas
depuis l'es3 puis four b2 qui perd trop
de temps comme on l'a vu ici nouveau
nouvelle tentative foudroie - fo 3 pas
mal ça développe logique des blocs là
une pièce tranquille or peut-être les
blancs là elles veulent jouer avec f4
oui régulièrement fait ses fans le plan
des blancs cédric est processes donc
pions processes saura conseiller
hautement conseillé pour éviter les lots
5 et une fois qu'on arrivera dans ces
structures donc les noirs auront trois
pions e6 des six essais 6 bien placé a
priori bien placé on jouera avec
cavaliers à 4 pour rentrer sur la case
des six essais 4 avec une structure
d'options complexe c'est ce qu'on va
voir ça c'est
ça s'est produit dans la partie suivant
les sept fous 17
donc là c'est un coût normal c'est à
dire qu en fait l'idée c'est que sur qui
les prend ses six bon on va reprendre du
pied mais de toute façon
mais le fou 1,17 et pas mal placée ce
qu'il faut mieux sortir il faut bien le
sortir
dames 2 un coût plus ou moins d'attentes
de développement on lit les tours c'est
tout à fait classique fawcett rouach
donc ça c'est en fait un cas où les
blancs savent pas trop à droite
c'est typiquement un coût qui prépare s4
c'est bien d'éviter toute possibilité
pour les noirs de protéger dauphin de
contre attaquer sur la diagonale à 7
juin c'est clairement pour jouer une
attaque avec efficace peut-être f5 ou
peut-être ça qui est intéressant
donc là c'est l'heure on n'a pas mis une
fois en 17 pour rien c'est pour jouer le
coup b5 les noirs de toute façon ils
doivent chercher du contre eux
donc quand les blancs ne joue pas à
quatre tours c'est fou 17 et des 5 tout
à fait normal mais cinq menace
évidemment stéphane b 4 puisque sur
camélia kath sûr qu'ils allaient prendre
des cartes calais prend des 4 et le
gabriac avait retraite emprise du fou 17
et si lecavalier c3 doit revenir sur la
case d1
il est pas beau il est pas beau mais la
gauche ouais donc ça ne va pas à 3 à 3
bon j'ai les quatre un petit rock
balkanique et maintenant le fameux f4
qui avait été préparé par rachat
exactement
même si c'est difficile pour les nord de
contre attaquer tout de suite sur cette
diagonale parce qu'elle fout et roi qui
veille
disons que c'est un coup prophylactique
à longue portée un rush
oui en plus ça permet régulièrement dans
les bars nantes où le cavalier arrivants
gkp par exemple quand il n'y a eu que 5
de mettre le feu sur laquelle j'ai un
ouais donc c'est en fait ça libère les
canadiens dont certains cas ici
maintenant la question c'est comment
attaquer les blancs puisque le plan de
blanc on le voit très clairement c'est
g4 g5 f5 ça rime avec une attaque tous
les pions à utaka double tranchant quand
même parce que en général
quand on a leur miroir du même côté on
est visite à pousser ses propres pions
puisqu'on a faibli peut-être un peu les
noirs mais on s'affaiblit aussi
dangereusement c'est vrai mais on prend
quand même une initiative assez forte
dans la mesure où dès qu'on fasse le
cavalier m6 on le rappelle qu'entre vous
et 11 17
ça devient extrêmement pénible oui mais
s'il n'y a pas beaucoup de cases ces
dispositions il va être aussi bien sur
la case 8 quand il faut le mettre à huit
c'est une cata sont donc maintenant se
pose le problème comment jouer une
position thématique de cécile ndash
dorff quand on les blancs n'ont pas
empêché b5 mais qu'ils ont réagi à b5
parra 3 comment poursuivre l' attaque
alors on ne peut pas jouer à 5 pour jour
des cas puisque pions bessin qui
systématiquement en prison elle
il faut donc faire autre chose voilà le
tout la problématique de cette position
puisque le plan des blancs est clair
alors souvent souvent ce type de
position et qu'elle fout et 3 donc ça
c'est de d'essayer d'arriver à mettre le
cavalier c6 sur la case ces quatre
exactement il attaque le cavalier
l'attaquent b2 ça c'est un premier plan
mais le problème de ce plan stéphane
c'est que le fou va revenir très
calmement c'est un même à jouer b2 b3 et
on n'aura toujours pas d' attaque donc
c'est une possibilité qu'il faut jamais
négliger anelka venu en c4 toujours
vérifier si ces forts ou pas fort en
l'occurrence elle n'est pas suffisamment
et quand ce n'est pas assez il faut
envoyer des moyens d'urgence parce que
là qu'il y a urgence et donc le plan
stéphane s'est régulièrement de jouer
des quatre pions prend des quatre pieds
premier 4 donc on affaiblit un petit peu
nos structures d'options puisque le pion
à 6 va se retrouver sous feu de la tour
on l'est de la dame et de la dame
mais c'est pas grave puisque nous on va
obtenir deux colonnes d et c est notre
idée en fait dans ce genre de position
c'est de faire diversion éviter tout
simplement de serre matez donc c'est ce
que fait x 9 tours fc 8 et non pas pour
assez vite et donc la tour assez vite ce
qui semble bizarre puisque finalement à
tours à huit est toujours quand même
sous le feu du fou j'ai deux oui donc on
a tous envie de mettre la torah 8
souvent c'est vite mais les tanneries
que pleins on sait jouer des 4 et
d'avoir les deux colonnes il fallait
jouer torres 6 8 me fous et froid dans
cette position pourquoi pas les blancs
continuent leurs attaques qu'ils
auraient pu tenter g4 tout de suite mais
c'est en fait non parce que sur gk tout
de suite il ya le thématiques qu'elle
prend des quatre fous prend des cats est
aussi inquiet de 5 qui cassent
complètement alors là il structure des
plans blancs va être terrible de saioua
songé cats et surtout sa gamme et un g4
fouere 3 donc maintenant tout rabais
vite voilà on a compris pourquoi on
avait joué l'autre tour ans et huit
exactement là on veut jouer très
clairement des 4 et après calais b 3
maintenant c'est l'heure des 4 b 4 puis
on prend bep cap qu'elle prend b4 et là
on reprend notre souffle on regarde bien
cette position
qu'est ce qu'on voit stéphanois des
menaces de partout qui est france et 2
qui doit pouvoir menacer assez
rapidement sous peu qu'on ait réussi à
tekken fois plus le cas et b3 on voit
également des cinq qui peut arriver au
programme on voit le fou ce 17 qui pour
sortir ans et six en tout cas le placer
le fou de casques blancs gilet blanc le
foot est roi n'a plus aucune pièce à
attaquer exactement ont ils tout a été
libéré et stéphane on voit bien quand
même que les tours font pression une
session grosse pression du côté dames
c'est vrai que c'est délicat
les tours sont plutôt belle donc ici
très belle position pour ifs kof
la partie continue mais enfin c'est
plutôt pas mal c'est plutôt une réussite
on va regarder notre 4e 3e parti stefan
wey donc là c'était sur la tentative fou
aux trois à la caf 4 donc on a vu la
première c'est qu'elle co2 et ces cas là
on voit fou et 3,4 maintenant on va voir
une nouveauté nouvelles idées donc
toujours un ordre de coûts curieux
puisque en fait avec la major fonds
n'arrivent pas trop les blanches ou
pages et 3 contres langage de l'enfant
général des gaves qui empruntent emprunt
2006 et ses trois des six
j'ai trois à six donc là en fait c'est
comme si on avait eu un âge d'or au
coude avant dans cette pression là si
l'option était en à 6 au lieu de 1,6 et
1,7 au lieu du contraire et on joue g3
et enjoint au site c'est comme si on
allait jouer aussi sa fougue et de
maintenant donc là on voit tout de suite
que les plans et b52 c'est toujours
extrêmement dangereux
comme d'habitude le cavalier des fois on
hésite à le sortir en 17 mais là on veut
absolument le maître ans et 6 pour
contrôler cette diagonale dame ces sept
on ne met pas tout de suite tombé après
petit rock kbc 6 maintenant hélas un
essai extrêmement direct stéphane
cavaliers pros qu'il aille car il prend
quelques pas vraiment faire plus
directement tout à fait alors la dame
prend se heurte à eux cinq ans qui
viennent un pion avec
fou j'ai deux se réveillant sur la dame
qui gagnent un bon pion central qui fait
très très mal qui fait très mal
donc comprend 7 6 et puis un prince et
six et maintenant cavalier à 4 comme il
ya 14 ça permet de jouer ces quatre
voilà et en même temps sa menace fou ou
trois avec invasion des cases mort avec
en tout cas pression sur laquelle ce
bâtiment là mais me des menaces dans
cette position il faut il faut bien
faire quelque chose faut choisir si on
met le fou en 17 ou en dix-sept ya le
choix
mais on préfère le mettre sur la case 17
pour une raison très simple c'est que la
caisse 17 appartient aux cavaliers m6
c'est ce cavalier là qu'il va venir là
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de plus sur
cette structure de pions puisqu'elle est
quand même très complexe au départ après
keziah cap stéphane il faut choisir
entre mon les blancs vont jouer ses
cartes ça c'est sûr il faudra choisir
entre ces 5 ou 1 5 mais pas les deux oui
oui parce que les deux s'affaiblit la
case des 5
voilà c'est jamais très bon mais c'est
vrai que c'est simple avantage c'est que
de sa bouche les possibilités foulée
trois voiliers et ça libérera le fond 17
si on joue décision juste c'est 5 de
toute façon ici on va vous montrer les
deux possibilités parce que les deux
possibilités se valent donc on va
commencer par regarder celle là fougue
et cette c4 c5
voilà libère avec les 17 sur les
attaques contre attaque sur k4 tout
simplement menace
voilà ça sera au théâtre c'est très
logique on attaque le pion aux 4 le
cavaly revient en c3 puisque quand on a
joué ses 5 il n'a strictement rien à
faire on a qu'à moi c'est normal
maintenant on sort nos pièces fou au 7è
les blancs jouer actifs pour une raison
très simple stéphane c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas d'autre plan c'est dire que le plan
des noirs on le voit très bien c'est
tout est flou ces sites
enfin petit rock évidemment m'être
peut-être une tour en 2 8 pouces et 6 et
poussé le pion à à sa main qui a quatre
attaques et b2c un plan vraiment
classique oui un cap des 3 ça va miner
la la phalange des pions blancs
tout à fait nous attaquent ils ont
attaqué sur la colonne b on va faire
valoir notre contre je donc les blancs
jouent f4 avec attaque ils tentent
d'attaquer
donc là on n'a pas toujours à chom parce
que le pion csn dont tu te sois empêche
les noirs de de faire un quelconque
échec sur la diagonale est ici
cavalier 17 c'est un coup d'évacuation
tranquille on veut pas laisser le camion
à 6 on le remet sur la case 17
bon ça c'est possible l'idée s'est
régulièrement de faux et 6 ça me
rappelle d'ailleurs une variante je
crois qu'on l'a montré dans la leçon une
vente comme ça où l'on joué avec vous et
si je sais plus avec elle c'est et avoir
toujours dans la ccn d'âge d'or
évidemment faux et 3 petit rock tient
tranquille g4 donc les blancs attaque
ils attaquent mais là y'a rien à
attaquer puisque cavaliers partie le
cavalier partie ici c'est une attaque un
petit peu dans le vide voilà ici les
noirs on joue un coup un peu
responsables ils ont joué 6 alors je ne
sais pas trop cissokho est bon en tout
cas moi j'aurais plutôt préconisé de
jouer simplement fous ces six c6 avec le
plan à 5 à 4 tours b mythe plan tout à
fait classique
c'est vrai qu'il faut être si ce bon
faut aussi sa menace peut-être font
prendre qu'avait laissé trois pour boyer
les pions blancs et par contre ça peut
ça peut être sous le feu de g4 g5
c'est le problème donc disons que la
partie a mal tourné pour les noirs après
flo 6 mai c'est dans cette position que
je voulais tout simplement vous
recommander de jouer le coup normal fous
ces six à quatre à cinq tours b 8 à 4
avec je pense une très belle position
pour les noirs voilà donc ce troisième
exemple nous allons passer au dernier
exemple qui est une partie entre deux
très fort joueur stéphane puisqu'il
s'agit de yves en dessous qui a les
blancs et kazim janov qui a les noirs
lankaise engine of on rappelle il est
n'est pas fou il est où ce bec liés aux
becs et les casaques en fait non kazakh
est il
qu'est ce qu'ils annoncent il a été
champion du monde du nord non non non
mais on devait compter dans le top 10
mondial
ouais il a plus de 2700 points elo donc
c'est un extrêmement fort joueurs vivent
de choc évidemment on ne présente plus
le joueur le plus fou de la planète qui
est complètement n'est pas fou il faut
freiner les dix sont différents il ya
différents eux quatre ces cinq cavaliers
f3 de 6 donc encore un ordre de coûts
alternatif des quatre petits enfants dès
4 ans des quatre pieds et ses 6 pi et
ces trois dames c'est 7
j'ai trois à six fours et 2006 petit
rock death is only
c'est encore notre position donc on a vu
les toutes les tentatives points
encaissés 2 ouais déjouer ces quatre
c'est fait c'est pas très fort nous joue
à trois on a vu deux ou trois donc sur
flu trois ont réagi normalement on fait
fou 17 fawcett et dessins qui marie avec
ensuite ce sera 3 b 4 tout à fait
logique
ça c'est une autre possibilité on a vu
également dans la partie précédente qui
est processes sûr qu'on reprend des
tubes et est ensuite tombé le fou en 17
jours les populations que s'il aimait
tant 17 comme on va le voir dans cette
partie et là nous voyons le coutour eu
un coup de renforcement qui menace
régulièrement ses fans des coutumes qui
est des cinq wake avec des cinq puisque
sur qui on prend on peut faire puis on
prend des 5 avec échelle comprend des
cinq échecs et sur calvillo cet énorme
des problèmes pour sortir leur pièce
c'est un sacrifice de pièces qui
arrivent régulièrement il faut s'en
méfier mais en tout cas pour l'instant
il ya fou 17 noms des sept qui est des
cinq
de toute évidence ne marche pas pour le
moment et laquelle prend ces six là
stéphane c'est un problème ça me prend
pour reprendre du fou s'alarme reprendre
du fonds n'a pas l'air mauvais ça a pas
l'air mauvais ne reprend du fou et
pourtant c'est ça pète et jouer je pense
à cause de qualité 5
oui parce qu'elle a un peu plus on peut
pas jouer tous ces six ans le 7 exercent
leur échec c'est le problème
on n'a pas le droit donc on ne peut pas
prendre du fou à cause de qui est des
cinq c'est toute l'idée donc on
reproduction b et les blancs ont réussi
par leur ordre de coups un peu curieux à
nous placer notre fou sur la case 17 au
lieu de ça change beaucoup de choses
hein tout à fait puisque maintenant on a
plus qu'à et 17 et ainsi de suite
en tout cas kazim janov a trouvé un
moyen très original de jouer dans cette
position sur cavani à 4 il joue tourbe
et vite
ouais donc ça c'est premier contrôle de
la case des six
b3 maintenant c'est normal il joue avec
eux cinq cette fois ci donc en fait il
faut il faut il faut bien faire
attention à ce qui se passe là c'est un
autre plan différent il nous a forcé
avec le fonds en 17
donc on joue avec le koup pions en cinq
mois l' avantage c'est que ça tue le g2
satuc complètement le fujian ensuite on
va sortir avec fawcett petit rock enfin
après ça va être énorme
la partie a poursuivi part d'amd 3 à 5
le pire était en prison les petits ont
été en plus il est bien plus ça donne la
caste des quatre qui peut être utile qui
est très utile de keersmaeker fou des
deux fosses est normal là pour l'instant
kazim geof il voit pas trop où ils vont
tous venir alors ils vendent tout fait
ces quatre petit rock
maintenant il ya eu torah c'est un art
menace probablement ces cinq exactement
mais c'est là justement qu'il faut pas
avoir peur
il a joué tous rêvent des beats avec
donc une idée très simple dans cette
position son prochain poussé deux fois
au 6 après sur ses seins qui aura
systématiquement des 5
donc ça a pas de problème il faut juste
vérifier dans cette position que c'est
ça qui ne marche pas et c'est ce qu'il a
fait donc on va récapituler sa position
qu'à numéro un
les glandes vous passez 5 ouais donc
dans ce cas le prochain point noir c'est
fou aux six ans 8 k et 17
on revient avec le cavalier ou aux
menaces des cinq mois la menace des
stands aussi c'est peut-être tout
simplement des 5 on peut je vous ai
fuite aussi bref y'a pas de problème le
cap critique stéphane c'est comme tu
l'as dit ces cinq voiliers parce que ça
casse la structure des pions noirs si on
prend ces 5
ça a l'air très mauvais pour les noirs
puisque le pion c6 va se retrouver sur
le feu de la tour c'est un hymne être
arriéré donc non défendu et
probablement il faudra prendre le cas
rien c'est 5 avec le four qui récupère
un fou donc qui est pas une bonne
nouvelle dans cette position donc il est
joué plus on prend ces cinq cas les
français 5 es fou g4 alors qu'est ce qui
se passe en fait là ils jouent pour
l'activité et le dynamisme et c'est là
qu'on va voir justement que sur ce coup
c'est sans que les noirs ont tellement
bien placé seul leur pièce que malgré
tous les inconvénients que tu as cité
c'était aller qui ont isolé
ouais lefort cavaliers ouais la tour sur
la colonne c'est qu'ils disent la dame
ça fait beaucoup beaucoup de choses les
noirs ont suffisamment de jeu mais à une
fourchette en racisme pour l'instant la
dame blanche est attaqué damas s'est
attaquée par leur éclatement faut faire
attention donc dame de 3 pouces et 8
bon pour l'instant salaires retraites
empêche car il ya six ans pêche qui veut
dire 6 et menaces tour des cats stéphane
il veut rentrer sont sur ces cases la
wii donkey les tours ces deux tours des
quatre tours au c1 ils vont de choc un
style typique
oui mais l'association c6 il a raison
c'est la faiblesse
maintenant il ya une âme des beats way
foule un tour b 5 on va s'arrêter là
pour cette partie parce que ça devient
très compliqué mais en tout cas c'est
serré quand même assez équilibré les
noirs ont suffisamment de jeu mais
contrôle très bien la colonne des
s'équilibre et les blancs menace
systématiquement par le plan c 6 mais ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que vous êtes hors
jeu le projet de hors-jeu la colonne des
appartient au noir exactement
autre phénomène très important on va
lire bien sortir le cavalier csn pour
attaquer ses six et dans ce cas là un
coup comme fou mais c'est tout vous des
fous 17,6 à vous aussi
donc pour protéger ses six peut-être à
huy info bessette permet de de tenir à
distance les tours parce qu'on va pas
sacrifier pour compte donc voilà donc on
a vu plein de possibilités stéphane donc
dans tous les cas c'est toujours les
plans classique on sort les pièces en
rock on joue b5 dès qu'on peut si les
blancs défendre par trois ans joue b 4 6
1 et o2 maroc si on sort les pièces et
on veut jouer des 5
donc pour résumer ce système avec g3
n'est pas spécialement dangereux puisque
régulièrement le fou se retrouve hors
jeu c'est bien le problème principal est
fou j'ai deux et passif donc en vous
donne rendez vous
donc les gens vous remercie d'avoir
suivi cette émission on vous donne
rendez vous très prochainement
stéphane donc et bien à bientôt bientôt
ouais enfin